ein tag an dem ein wohnblock in kiew
bombardiert wurde zwei menschen dort
gestorben sind und mindestens neun
verletzt schauen wir uns genau an wie
die ukraine heute an diesem kriegstag
dasteht wie die bedrohung konkret für
dieses land aussieht auf einer karte die
das land zeigt und die auszeit von
welcher seite russland auf die ukraine
zu dringt und sie wissen genau das
betrifft natürlich vor allem die
östlichen gebiete dort in der ukraine
und die menschen die dort sind die
banken gerade besonders um ihr leben das
haben wir hier einmal auf dieser karte
rot eingezeichnet rot sehen sie
natürlich und mehr halbinsel krim den
süden und dann sehen sie auch wenn sie
etwas östlicher gehen die hart umkämpfte
stadt mariupol dort wir erinnern uns
vergangene woche der angriff auf ein
geburts krankheits also eine
kinderklinik dort heute die schreckliche
nachricht dass eine schwangere frau und
ihr ungeborenes kind dabei verstorben
ist sondern sehen sie weiter die grenzen
zu russland die städte die sich hieraus
unsere nachrichten auch so sehr kennen
charkiw beispielsweise sumi die städte
die besonders betroffen sind sie sehen
aber dann auch im norden der ukraine wie
stark sich dieses band richtung kiew
bewegt und der rest des landes wenn der
nicht rot es bedeutet das nicht dass es
da keine kriegshandlung gibt das haben
ja eben aus kiew gesehen das haben wir
aber gestern eben auch aus der region
lemberg gesehen also ganz links auf der
karte ganz nah an der polnischen grenze
im westen der ukraine das ist kein
sicheres gebiet mehr das galt in den
ersten kriegstagen noch als solche ist
aber gestern schwerer beschuss
raketenangriffe auch dort vor der
haustür von lemberg und darüber wollen
wir sprechen mit dem
politikwissenschaftler von der uni bonn
mit frank umbach schönen guten tag herr
umbach denn das ja was wir da gestern
gesehen haben in der region lemberg das
war ja ein raketenangriff mit acht
russischen raketen auf diese
militärbasis aber das war doch mehr das
war eine provokation direkt an der
grenze zur nato
das ist völlig richtig
man musste das allerdings auch in den in
der letzten woche schon erwarten putin
hat natürlich so lud kein interesse
daran dass der westen über die
gemeinsame grenze zwischen der ukraine
und polen
waffen liefert und damit sozusagen den
widerstand natürlich anheizt und dann
müssen wir uns noch mal daran erinnern
an diese ursprüngliche nuklear
ausgestoßen worden ist und dieses teil
der russischen militärdoktrin und
strategie die aber bei uns völlig falsch
wiedergegeben wird oder beziehungsweise
diese militär strategischen debatten
sind bei uns in den letzten jahren nicht
verfolgt worden denn putin verfolgt eine
kriegsführung eine konventionelle an
kriegs
kriegführung unter dem deckmantel von
nuklearwaffen das heißt nicht dass er
nuklear waffen auch einsetzen will
geschweige denn dass er den dritten
weltkrieg damit auslösen will sondern
erzielt das ist teil einer politisch
psychologische kriegführung um den
westen völlig aus diesem konflikt
herauszuhalten einschließlich dass er
keine waffenlieferungen eben durchführt
und das führt dazu dass er mann spricht
militärstrategie ich von einer
militärischen eskalation dominanz das
heißt er kann den krieg dann führen ohne
jegliche einschränkungen keine rücksicht
zu nehmen auf das völkerrecht keine
rücksicht zu nehmen auf die bevölkerung
weil wir es ihm letztlich erlauben und
hätten wir am anfang nicht klappt so
klargestellt dass wir generell nicht
intervenieren wollen dann hätte er
natürlich darauf rücksicht nehmen müssen
das hätte zweifel gegeben das heißt
nicht dass wir dann sofort interveniert
hätten in diesem krieg aber diese
unsicherheit dann auch seiner seite was
tut der westen hätte eine ganz andere
kriegführung ermöglicht mit viel mehr
einschränkungen weil er nie gewusst
hätte ob der westen dann nicht doch
entsprechend reagiert und das ist ein
strategischer fehler auf unserer seite
der nicht zu einer konflikt
einschränkung führt sondern faktisch ihm
sozusagen in die hände spielt also
sprich auch die nato hat in der
vergangenheit zu defensiv reagiert in
ihren augen ist das etwas was sich jetzt
in den kommenden tagen und wochen noch
entwickeln kann wie es da ihr ganz
konkreter ratschlag wie das bündnis
reagieren soll
also ich glaube dass es gibt sicherlich
gute gründe warum es dazu gekommen ist
das hatte auch damit zu tun dass wir am
anfang eher davon ausgegangen sind dass
es eben keinen direkten maß zum beispiel
auf kiew gibt und dass putin die gesamte
ukraine besetzen will das war ja nicht
das wahrscheinliche szenario von dem wir
ausgegangen sind und da haben wir uns
das muss man leider knallhart sagen wir
uns strategisch täuschen lassen und wir
stehen vor einem dilemma nämlich dass
wir an konventionell angriffskriege
russland sozusagen erlaubten unter
diesem deckmantel einer nuklear drogen
und putin war immer davon ausgegangen
dass wissen wir dass er politik dass er
die europäischen politiker insbesondere
für schwach hält und er seien kgb agent
und das wichtigste instrument eines
kgb-agenten ist immer angst zu holen der
innen- wie in der aussenpolitik das ziel
sozusagen auf die politische der
bereitschaft des westens und in dieser
hinsicht hat sich putin
unglücklicherweise eben nicht kalkuliert
sondern die westlichen reaktionen haben
ihnen darin bestätigt dass wir so viel
angst haben dass wir militärisch
entsprechen nicht eingreifen und das
sozusagen spielt ihn militärisch in die
hände auf dem weg zu einer weiteren
eskalation möglicherweise droht ja dass
putin sich irgendetwas als vorwand nimmt
um dann eben den konflikt den krieg
auszuweiten ein solcher vorwand könnte
sein dass es möglicherweise nato
militärberater in der ukraine gibt die
im einsatz sind dass ein bestimmtes maß
an waffenlieferungen daneben als aktives
eingreifen der nato
sozusagen gedeutet wird im kreml sehen
sie einen solchen vorwand sehen sie die
gefahr einer solchen eskalation aufgrund
eines solchen vorwärts
ich sehe einerseits die gefahr einer
eskalation ich sehe aber vor allem dass
russland nach wie vor kein interesse hat
dass der westen hier eingreift und
insoweit ist das ein politisches
ökologisches spiel auf die westliche
politik entsprechend einzuwirken
weiterhin sich in keinster weise in ein
möchte in diesem konflikt und wenn es
nach ihm ginge da muss man sich noch
einmal an die nuklearen erinnern das war
die drohung war ja auch darauf gemünzt
dass wir ja auch keine
wirtschaftssanktionen erheben ja das
heißt er spielt mit unseren ängsten und
wir erlauben ihm ist nicht klare rote
linien hier zu ziehen und so lange wir
dazu eben nicht bereit ist ist die frage
warum er in seiner kriegführung auch in
der eskalation davon abrücken soll weil
letztendlich die politischen signale die
wir mit dieser entscheidung sendet zu
heben sind eben dass er nach wie vor
entsprechend dann keine rücksicht nehmen
muss auf den besten ich glaube aber
nicht dass ist erstens zu einem dritten
weltkrieg kommt es völliger blödsinn und
ich glaube auch nicht dass er
davon ausgeht dass der westen er
entsprechend interveniert und solange
wir diese ratio in seiner
erwartungshaltung nicht ändern besteht
diese art von kriegsführung ford mit
allen konsequenzen die das hat auch
einer weiteren eskalation
zu der wir dann selbst dann auch
getrieben werden ohne entsprechend einen
wirklichen plan zu haben also mehr
drohen mehr stärke zeigen für weniger
krieg wenn ich das mit meinen worten
kurz zusammenfassen darf danke herr
rombach für das gespräch vielen dank